this video is brought to you by skill
share the first 500 people to sign up
with the link in the description will
get a 2 month free trial what's up
everyone
disembody jarrett again man the DC EU
has had a pretty rough go of it we've
already broken down what went wrong in
Batman V Superman and Suicide Squad but
today we're going back to the source of
all these issues the movie that began
Zack Snyder's vision of the DC Universe
that gave birth to moustache game [ __ ]
stamp Joker Momoa dead eyes Wonder Woman
okay that one was pretty great did
never-ending will they or won't they all
ultimately leading to the tragically
bland corporate mandated void that is
the Justice League but none of this
would exist if it weren't for the film
that set the tone Man of Steel by trying
to graft darkness and grit onto a
character devoid of such qualities Man
of Steel stumbles into a mess that would
ultimately doom the DC EU
so let's rotate the earth back half a
decade and see how the DC EU went so
wrong so early welcome to this wisecrack
edition on Man of Steel what went wrong
and as always spoilers ahead back in
2013
DC films was riding high after the
critical and financial success of
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
those films successfully merged be pop
aesthetic of a superhero film with a
previously unmatched sense of wait no
one export the darker aspects of being
the Batman questioning whether the
vigilante himself was a destructive
force did Batman begin the very cycle of
violence he fights against with the
Joker Bane and all the rest of these
villains ever have come to fruition if
he didn't exist if true what good is
Batman are supposed heroes is he a
necessary evil
these are weighty questions to ask and
yet the Dark Knight trilogy never tipped
over into pomposity the rare superhero
films to be both smart and entertaining
it's no surprise then that DC wanted to
recreate this same success but their
other tentpole comic characters Superman
I mean those Christopher Nolan Batman
films sure were successful so why not do
the exact same thing for Superman seems
like a surefire hit what could go wrong
so the powers that be hired another dark
and gritty filmmaker Watchmen and 300
sacks Snyder brought in
writer of the Dark Knight trilogy and
even gave our boy Nolan a story credit
and producer role there's just one
little problem
Superman isn't Batman the darkness and
wait intrinsic to Batman and emotionally
scarred vigilante avenging the death of
his parents just isn't true for Superman
on the contrary Superman is supposed to
be the ideal all-powerful yet completely
pure there's not a malevolent bone in
his body he's the ultimate good guy so
how the hell do you impose darkness grit
and weight onto the symbol of hope
what's the S stand for on my world it
means hope first nighter the answer
didn't lie with Superman but in the
world around him America has changed a
whole lot since Superman's comic book
introduction in 1938 where once upon a
time the huge guys and bad guys were
easy to deduce and label at the time Man
of Steel was written the endless war on
terror had muddied the waters wanton of
obey xenophobia and insufficient veteran
services painting America as a far cry
from the supposed shining city on a hill
Man of Steel questions if Superman the
embodiment of the American ideal can
survive in the current disillusioned
America will he be accepted or rejected
ostensibly it's a coming-out story where
the central question becomes should
Superman reveal himself to society and
lest anyone ever accused Man of Steel of
being subtle when Clark first discovers
his powers during class he runs away and
hides out in you guessed it a closet so
what answer does the film provide should
Superman remain in the closet or reveal
his powers and save the world like the
hero he's always been well the answer
becomes far darker and murkier than
you'd expect after young Clark saves a
bus full of students from drowning
Jonathan Kent tells him that maybe he
shouldn't have what was I supposed to do
just let him die
maybe let that sink in the all-american
dad tells the burgeoning hero he should
probably just let a bunch of children
drown the crazier part Man of Steel
treats this advice as sound Johnathan in
the same scene tells Clark that there's
more at stake than the lives of a bunch
of children the world finds out what you
can do it's gonna change everything our
beliefs our notions over what it means
to be human
everything jonathan fears that when
confronted with who and what Clark is
people will fear and reject him
humanity's very reality will shatter and
the results won't be pretty and guess
what throughout Man of Steel we see this
to be exactly the case when Clark hides
in the closet after discovering his
powers he hears the children afraid of
him when Perry Mason hears about the
possibility of Superman's existence he
remarks can you imagine how people on
this planet would react if they knew
there was someone like this out there
even Lois Lane Superman's true paramour
is afraid when she first sees the
almighty alien the questions raised by
my rescuers existence are frightening to
contemplate if Clark does decide to come
out well it could end in his death case
in point as a teenager
Clark is framed reading a book on the
philosopher Plato Plato actually
detailed what would happen if a
perfectly just and righteous man were to
ever come into the world a man just like
Superman in the Republic one of
Socrates's pals suggests that this
perfect man will be scourge racked bound
people have his eyes burned out and at
last after suffering every kind of evil
he will be impaled so not good if
Superman were to reveal his identity
inevitably people would turn against him
and seek to kill him a fate we see play
out in Batman V Superman Snyder drives
this point home by comparing the hero to
the other all good being in human
history Jesus was an act of God Jonathan
this was Providence when Clarke debates
with a priest about whether he should
reveal his identity he's framed in the
foreground with a stained glass
depiction of Jesus in the background and
later when Superman rescues Lois from an
escape pod we see him in the classic
crucifixion pose again not very subtle
by comparing Superman with Christ Snyder
has a real sense of foreboding too Man
of Steel because well we all know how
Jesus's story ends and herein lies the
problem
Clark has to become Superman because the
movies called Man of Steel not hipster
sad beard man but Man of Steel puts
itself into a corner where it's
constantly arguing Clark shouldn't
reveal his powers that if he does become
Superman
he will be feared hated and inevitably
murdered there's no logical reason for
Clark to reveal himself to the world so
this leads to two issues one Clark
becomes a reluctant hero and two the
entire film becomes a refusal of the
call now the reluctant hero is a
well-worn narrative archetype in which a
person is thrust into circumstance where
he must save the day despite never
really wanting to do so think Han Solo
in Star Wars or John McClane and die
hard this hero doesn't ever look to save
anybody he's just drawn into situations
where he must
similarly Clark doesn't look to save
anybody in Man of Steel he just sort of
ends up at the right place at the right
time the school bus crash
well Clark's already on the bus so why
not the oil rig disaster Clark's on a
nearby fishing boat so why not again
Lois gets attacked by a tentacled
etch-a-sketch Clark's only a couple feet
away you get the point
but this reluctant hero archetype is the
antithesis of the Superman mythos if
Superman is the ideal we strive to be
the hero among heroes then his
reluctance to save anybody runs contrary
to his ethos further by making Superman
a reluctant hero it turns him into a
passive character things happen to Clark
the bus crashed the oil rig disaster a
stage five tornado as opposed to Clark
leading the narrative through action the
entire film in turn becomes a refusal of
the call / Joseph Campbell's hero's
journey when our hero is first called
into action he chooses to refuse often
because staying at home is easier and
far less dangerous
for example in Star Wars a new hope Luke
initially refuses to help obi-wan save
Princess Leia it's only when Luke
returns home to see his house destroyed
and his aunt and uncle dead that he
decides to take up action the refusal of
the call is typically only a brief stop
on the hero's journey in Campbell
monomyth it takes up less than a 17th of
the hero's journey yet in Man of Steel
Clarke refuses the call to become
Superman for over half the film more
than an hour of runtime imagine if Luke
had spent over an hour contemplating the
pros and cons of using the Force you'd
grow to hate the guy this becomes the
problem in Man of Steel Clarke spends so
much time debating the merits of
becoming a hero that in the end he seems
like a bit of a dick I mean he's an
almighty all-powerful being who can save
the earth on one leg with only his
pinkie and yet we the audience are asked
to sympathize with why he shouldn't save
anybody when Jonathan Kent gets sucked
up into a tornado Man of Steel's intent
is to to pick the moment as a tragic
lesson but in execution well it's far
less Clark could save his paw from
imminent death but can't because doing
so would reveal his powers to too many I
let my father die because I trusted him
because he was convinced that I had to
wait
at the world is not ready yet again Man
of Steel treats this as a completely
reasonable action like of course that's
what anyone would do
Superman should just let his father die
because there's at least 25 people under
the bridge watching even more the blame
is placed on the world it's our fault
Jonathan Kent died where - in Nobel not
the superhero that could have saved him
in oh I don't know two seconds Man of
Steel carries this cynicism to its
conclusion where Superman and Zod Duke
it out in Metropolis nonchalantly
killing hundreds of thousands if not
more but it's not Superman who is
capital dear to this loss of life but
the film itself Man of Steel doesn't
realize the implication this conclusion
has on Superman and his heroic ethos the
ending has treated it as a triumph
Superman defeat Zod and saves the world
who cares about a couple hundred
thousand extras Lois is fine get over it
humanity never even accepts Superman
after Clark reveals his powers and sort
of saves metropolis the government
tracks him with a drone questioning his
motives how do we know you won't one day
act against America's interests Superman
too doesn't trust humanity
destroying the affer mentioned drone and
telling the government to take a hike
that they'll never find out where he
hangs his cape so in the end the uneasy
relationship between humanity and
Superman is still well exactly that the
world still isn't ready early in Man of
Steel Clark's birth father jor-el echoes
the idealistic sentiments of Superman's
past he will give the people of Earth an
ideal to strive towards
they'll race behind you they will
stumble they will fall but in time they
will join you in the Sun down in time it
will help them accomplish wonders this
is the Superman of the 1930s of Richard
Donner and Christopher Reeve but the
words ring hollow in Snyder's morally
obfuscated worldview by the end of Man
of Steel Snyder has crafted a Superman
who shouldn't have saved a bus full of
children who let his father die and
destroyed the city he sought to protect
all the idealism of yesteryear has been
sucked out leaving a hollow shell where
once stood a beacon of hope Man of
Steel's intent is to pave the way for
Superman and the DC EU to showcase the
uplifting origins of the greatest of
Heroes and begin a multi crossover film
franchise but in reality the film has
the exact opposite reaction the wanton
destruction of the third act the
wishy-washy hero the morally obfuscated
world all paint a picture far from
idealistic this isn't an uplifting story
of a hero coming into his own and being
accepted by the world this is a story of
a hero being forced into hiding
ultimately rejected in fear by the
government and the people he seeks to
protect that darkness and grit the very
thing Man of Steel adds ironically
enough becomes its own undoing
swallowing up the inherent goodness of
its central character turning the
beginnings of the DCU franchise into the
origins of its end thanks for watching
guys and as always peace like lots of
other youtubers you guys often ask us
how we make our videos which programs we
use and how we learn to use them at
wisecrack many of us taught ourselves
how to master the applications we use
today luckily you can learn just about
anything online if you ever wanted to
start a project or learn a new skill but
weren't sure where to begin Skillshare
can help get you started skill share is
an online learning community with over
17,000 professional and easy-to-use
classes and design photography business
and more whether you're already a
creator or you're looking to become one
you'll find like-minded people with
steps and advice on how to take your
ideas to the next
you can take classes on everything from
drawing with ink to how to design a
mobile app - how to properly chop
vegetables a premium membership is super
affordable and starts at just $10 a
month you'll get unlimited access to the
full range of courses but the first 500
people to click the link in the
description will receive a free two
month trial - Skillshare and all its
amazing resources so head over to sk l
sh slash wisecrack for to be in your 2
month free trial and get learning we
can't wait to see what you create and
don't forget to subscribe and ring that
bell so you never miss what we create
thanks for watching and catch all next
time guys peace